MALE SPEAKER: Great.
Well, welcome everyone.
I'm glad you all could make it,
even though it's a day of
the "Star Trek" opening,
and some other
exciting geek events.
But we're in for real
treat today.
We have Eric Hautemont.
And that's really testing my
high school French there, but
I hope I said it right.
He's the co-founder and
CEO of board game
publisher, Days of Wonder.
So let's give him hand,
first of all.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: So Eric and his
co-founder, Mark Kaufman,
started Days of Wonder
in 2002.
And they've just won a lot
of awards, including a
prestigious German Game of the
Year award, again, which will
test the limits of my European
languages, so I won't try.
But they've won many other
industry awards for their
blockbuster title, "Ticket to
Ride." And they are one of the
youngest companies to ever win
the prestigious German award.
They also have a top-selling
app store game.
And so in the digital world of
Silicon Valley, Eric and Mark
have dared to go analog.
And as you can tell, that's
paid off pretty well.
But actually, Eric is also
from a background of
technology.
He was at companies like Ray
Dream, which was a 3D Mac
software developer.
And he was at Fractal
Design before.
And so here today, he'll give
a talk, and a Q&A. And he'll
sort of talk about his path
towards going from digital to
analog, why he decided to start
a board game company.
And then at the end, we'll
actually have a chance to play
board games with him.
He has some "Ticket to
Ride" boxes here.
And so if you stick around,
towards the end,
we'll have some fun.
So without further ado, let me
introduce Eric to the stage.
ERIC HAUTEMONT: Thank
you, [INAUDIBLE].
Thank you.
Hello, everyone.
It's a pleasure to be here.
It was kind of fun driving down
the shoreline, because I
used to work at about two blocks
from here 20 years ago.
So that brought back some
good memories, back
in the digital days.
But what I'd like to talk about
today is something a bit
different, and that's
board games.
And the reason why board games
are different is they're
different from any other form
of entertainment, and really
any other form of consumer
product you can think of.
And they're different in a big
way, but that takes a while,
especially when you're coming
from the digital side, like I
did, to kind of like sink it.
And the big difference is
how long they last.
To put some things in
perspective, the best selling
board game today, in terms of
number of units sold, if not
profit, is still a game called
"Monopoly," which was the best
selling title back in 1935.
Now that's kind of like if Errol
Flynn was making more
money this year than
Brad Pitt.
Or if Cole Porter was outselling
Lady Gaga, which
needless to say, no one
expects would happen.
Right?
And what's interesting is, if
you look even at the packaged
goods business--
you look at something like
Campbell's Soup, for instance--
and their packaged good
business, their soup, has
changed more as a product than
has "Monopoly." And that is
one thing that gave us pause
as we were starting the
business, but that was one of
the things that attracted us
to that business.
And the reason that it attracted
us to the business
is because in another life, my
partner and I used to run high
tech companies.
I ran a photographics company in
the late '80s, early '90s,
called Ray Dream, which was
doing photographic software.
And while that was fun, and we
learned a lot, one thing that
I felt frustrated with is, we
sold that company to a company
called Fractal Design, which
had just gone public.
And two years later, I was
offered to buy back that
company, which I had sold
to them for over $50
million, for $1.
And I politely declined, and I
was right to decline because a
friend of mine who [INAUDIBLE]
lost his shirt.
But what was frustrating about
that was, that while you can
make money and learn things,
there's very few companies--
and Google is one of the
exceptions, so I think you
guys are lucky--
that can really stand the test
of time on the digital side.
And so that's one thing that
was very attractive to us
about the board game business.
Now, the flip side of that, of
course, is that means the
incumbents, the "Monopolies" of
the world, if they've been
on top for the last 80
years, how are you
going to displace them?
Or how are you going to carve
your own place in the sun in
that market?
And that's an interesting
challenge.
So when we started the company,
we had a theory, and
we had a bet.
The theory was that the main
reason why those games can
stand for so long at the top is
not because they have the
best game design out there.
I mean clearly, since
"Monopoly," game design has
evolved a lot.
You have games now, like
"Settlers of Catan" and
"Ticket to Ride," that arguably
are better from a
plain game design standpoint.
So how come "Monopoly"
is still on top?
Well, we think the reason that
is if we were to take people
up front that are in this room,
or anywhere else in the
world, for that matter, and I
was to invite some of you to
my house to play a game, no
matter what's the game.
Let's just assume it's
a good game.
We'll play together.
Eight out of 10 of you at least,
if not more, will have
a great time.
And at the end of the evening,
you'll say, that was great.
Where can I go and
buy this game?
Now, I take the exact same
sample of people, so the exact
same people, and I give you a
copy of the same game we were
playing that night in
the shrink wrap.
And I call you back in six
months, and I ask you how you
like the game.
And a large number of you won't
even have cracked the
shrink wrap open.
OK?
And so that was the theory.
The theory was that while people
enjoy playing board
games, they don't like having to
figure out how to play the
game that much.
OK?
The bet was that if that theory
is true, then what
really matters, as a board game
company, is how can you
get the large number of people
to play the game correctly
while getting them over
that initial fear?
And truth be told, what's
interesting with games like
"Monopoly" is that most people
don't play the game right.
And most people, when they go
and buy a box of "Monopoly,"
they buy it because they
remember buying it as a kid,
and playing it--
not buying it as a kid, but
playing it as a kid.
And then truth be told, what
they'll do is they'll open the
box, and they'll quickly browse
through the rules.
And they will still play
it wrong, by the way.
But which is a different issue,
which is that great
game designs, I think,
are very [INAUDIBLE]
to errors in the way
you play that.
So the interesting question then
was that if that theory
is true, how do you reach a lot
of the people, and teach
them the game?
And we felt that doing digital
editions of the games would be
a great way to do that.
And the bet we made was that
maybe if we did digital
versions of our board games,
right, we could develop a
virtual circle where the sales
of the physical board games
would drive downloads of the
digital games, and the
download of the digital games
would drive the sales of the
board game.
And you'd have that happy loop
that they develop together.
So the question then becomes,
the only question that really
matters as a board game company,
even though you're
dealing with real cardboard
pieces like that, is how do
you make sure that your digital
version is as good as
your board game version?
Your cardboard version?
I think before we go into the
challenges about designing the
digital editions of the board
games, one thing I'd like to,
I'd like to do some more
differences between the
digital side and the
cardboard side.
So what's interesting about
the cardboard side is that
it's relatively quick and
cheap to develop.
The typical board game today,
I'd say you can go and put a
real cardboard board game in the
market for under $20,000.
And you can develop that
in a couple of months.
It's kind of tough to do the
same thing under the same
budget and the same time frame
with a digital game.
So that's one thing that is in
favor of the cardboard side.
The other thing that is
interesting about the
cardboard is that people develop
this really unique,
very strong, emotional
attachment to the game itself.
So again, taking some examples,
if you take a game
box like this, even if you end
up opening this game, and not
playing it for many years, and
putting it away in a corner,
one day you'll be just wanting
to open it again.
And you're going to go, gee, I
want to clean my apartment.
Let's throw this, and then
you're going to keep it.
And most of the time, when you
get above the trash can,
you're going to say, no.
Looks too good.
I'm too attached to it.
I have good memories to it, and
you're putting it back.
Or you're playing it again.
OK?
Whereas, if you have a digital
version, there's, I think,
much less of a hangup to just
pressing the Delete button.
So there's a unique, emotional
attachment.
Now, the flip side of that,
and the bad thing on the
cardboard side, as you can
imagine what happens when
you're trying to ship hundreds
of thousands of these boxes
across the oceans with
a small company.
OK?
That's kind of a pain.
It's definitely harder than just
publishing something on
the Google Play Store
or the app store.
The other thing in favor of the
digital side is the price.
It tends to be a lot more
excited, and a lot more
willing to talk about digital
stuff than they are about
traditional card games
or board games.
So that's a plus on
the digital side.
And these are the main
differences that we see
between the cardboard side
and the digital side.
Now, let's talk about game
design and where the
challenges are.
So the thing that is very
particular about board games
as a problem for development
is that the rules you're
dealing with have to
be very simple.
And the reason why those rules
have to be simple is because
you're playing with those
rules in your head.
OK?
So there's a minimum of keep
you're willing to do.
And if you try to do too
much, it's just not
going to be much fun.
And so what that means is that--
that's what I call
nowhere to hide.
There's no fancy graphics that
can hide a bad game.
If the interaction of your rule
set with the players who
are playing it is not fun,
there's no fancy graphic that
is going to save you.
The flip side of that is that
also means that when you
design a digital prototype
of the game, you can
design it in text mode.
That's what we did with the very
first digital version of
the game we had.
We had a smaller card game we
launched in the company we've
called "Gang of Four." And
initially, we developed a very
simple text-based
version of that.
And the minute we knew the thing
was going to work is
when we started playing
that multi-player card
game in text mode.
Because that was fun, even
though it was in text mode.
And so my point is, if you have
a game that is fun with
sucky graphics, or in
text mode, you know
you have a real winner.
OK?
So that's one thing that is
really important to focus on.
The next thing is that board
games are fun because you're
playing this simple set
of rules against
another human being.
So yes, we can develop
artificial
intelligence opponents.
And for some games, you can
actually develop world-class
AI that will beat the
hell out of you.
But that's not what is fun.
What is really fun is
interacting with other people,
and being able to compete mind
against mind with all the
weakness and logic that
comes with that.
And that creates a set of
interesting issues from a
development standpoint.
One of the interesting issues is
the board games tend to be
turn based.
So you would think, well,
they're perfect
asynchronous games.
Well, except when you look at
how people really play board
games, they aren't exactly
playing them asynchronously.
I mean, yes, they are taking
their turns, but they're
playing in one game session.
You've don't like to
play over a billion
different game sessions.
And what we ended up discovering
is that what
people really, really wanted
then-- and sometimes don't
know how to express it-- but
what they really want with a
digital board game is they want
the best of both worlds.
They want to be able to stop the
game asynchronously, and
to start the game whatever they
want, because they might
not be face to face with the
other online players.
But at the same time, when they
happen to be together,
they want the game to perform
like a real-time game.
So that's created some
difficulties.
And I said the [INAUDIBLE] to
develop a basic board game
that people can enjoy
as a multiplayer
online games is this.
It's quite significant as a
result of on those issues.
So let's talk now about some
of the specific design
challenges that we see.
One of the challenges
is what kind of
information do you display?
When you have a real board game,
you don't ask yourself,
what am I displaying?
Because if there is
a stack of cards,
there's a stack of cards.
And everybody is looking at this
stack of cards, and gets
the same information.
Now, when you display that stack
of cards on the computer
screen, or any electronic
device, you don't have the
same resolution.
You don't have the same
perception of depth that you
have with the real
deck of cards.
So at what point do you start
showing people that there's
only a few cards left
in the deck?
And how do you display
that information?
Do you actually put a number
that says, there's only three
cards left in the deck, Eric?
Or how do you account
for that?
This, I assure you,
is non-trivial.
The other issue that is
non-trivial is in the real
world, you can deal with
something that is quite large.
OK?
So you take a board, a
game board like this.
OK?
And you lay pretty, plastic
trains on them.
And the information really
jumps at you.
So when you're trying to
connect, let's say Vancouver
to Atlanta, it's quite obvious
on the map where
those things are.
When you're dealing with a
screen, whether it's a tablet
screen, or even worse, if you're
dealing with a smaller
format screen, it's a lot
harder to see that
information.
And it's a lot easier
to miss some things.
So you're tempted to do things
that help prompt the user, and
say, OK, these are
your objectives.
Well, the problem is in the
real world, you don't have
something that flashes on the
board, these are your
objectives.
Because everybody else
would see it.
Right?
And again, this kind of subtle
design changes change the
flavor of the game.
So you have to be super careful
when you implement the
game, and you decide what
information to display.
You have to really think through
how that's going to
impact to the game.
Another issue is that reality
tends to be a lot more complex
than it looks.
So going back to our first game,
"Gang of Four," so it's
trick-taking game where
you have 64 cards.
You play with four players.
Each players has 16 cards.
And you're trying to get rid of
your cards before the other
players do.
And there's this thing, which
gives the game it's name,
called the "Gang of Four," where
if you have four of a
kind, that acts as a trump.
And that allows you to play
on anyone's hand.
And when we started programming
that game, people
complained, the game
is broken.
There's way too many
"Gang of Fours.
And so, of course, if everybody
has trumps in their
hands, the game kind
of breaks down.
And so we looked at the
code initially.
And we're thinking, OK, maybe
there's a bug somewhere.
So we run some starts, and
we look at actual game
plays, and so on.
And the odds of having a "Gang
of Four," are exactly what
that the maps say it should.
So we go, wait.
There is no error in the
way we programmed this.
And then we realized the error
is a human error that is
actually built in the physical
game itself, and that the game
realized that you don't need it
to work, which is that when
you play with a real deck of
cards, you will not truly do,
that is, most humans won't
really, truly do a random
shuffle from one end
to the next.
OK?
And if you do a true,
random shuffle, the
game will break down.
I grant you that.
So if you guys play "Gang
of Four," don't
shuffle it too much.
OK?
What that means is we had to
actually go back and program a
real shuffle that kind of mimics
the way you would truly
shuffle the deck.
Because otherwise, the
game does break down.
So that's one example.
There's another even more
embarrassing and simple
example of reality being more
complex than it looks, or
deeper and richer than it
looks, which is almost
embarrassing to admit, which is
linked to another game we
have called "Small World." And
in "Small World," it's kind of
like a fantasy game of "Risk."
and you have a die.
And that die you can roll on
your last conquest to try to
grab your territory.
And that die has a feature that
is a bit unique, which is
that there's one side with one
pip, one with two, one with
three, and the other three
sides happen to be blank.
OK.
No big deal.
When you play with the real
game, you grab the die.
It seemed to really
jump at you.
I don't need to write
anything in the
rules that says, beware.
This dice has three
blank sides.
OK?
Well, when we programmed the
electronic version, we started
getting lots of reviews.
And on the upside, it's very
frustrating because you can't
leave feedback or answers to
these people on their reviews.
They're saying, the
game is cheating.
I'm always rolling blanks.
I'd realize, well, yeah.
it's rolling the die for you.
And when it's rolling on the
screen, you don't really ever
get a chance to see it's
literally side by side.
It kind of rolls too fast.
It rolls like a real die, and
you can't really know that
there's three blank sides.
So that's another example where
you really need to be
careful about how you handle
the display of information,
and how you translate the
physical components into the
digital site.
One of the challenges is
the perception of time.
When you're playing face
to face, you have the
interaction.
And that's true by the way--
it's not so much a digital
versus cardboard issue here.
It's an issue of playing face
to face verus playing online
against people that are on
the remote connection.
Which is that when you are
playing face to face, there is
so many human interactions that
doesn't really pertain to
the game itself, that comes
into play, that your
perception of time is vastly
different from what it is when
you just focus, looking
on your screen.
OK?
And what that means is in a game
like "Gang of Four" where
you can play a hand or you
can pass, even if you
could play that hand.
And that information is crucial,
because it's giving
me, as your opponent, a
lot of information.
If I see that you hesitate
about passing, I know
something about your hand that
you don't want me to know.
And what's happening is when
you're just watching the
screen, you have no
one to look at.
So you're missing that whole,
additional information, social
information.
And as a result of that--
and we did this, really
timed it.
We did the test--
If you pause for even
less than a half a
second, we will notice.
Or the good players
will notice.
OK?
And that's something
they would never
notice in the real world.
OK?
So that is a challenge, and that
means that people will
play the game differently.
And you have to accept that
there's some things you just
won't to be able to change, and
people will play the game
differently.
Another example of that is
because you have no one to
look at, and interact with
directly, you will focus on
what information you're
presented with.
So again, looking at that very
simple card game, "Gang of
Four," it's a game where there's
four players, but
there's only one winner.
And there's no second,
third, fourth player.
You're either the winner,
or you lost.
And when you play the game
online, all you get to see at
is potentially an avatar, the
name of that avatar, which we
usually don't change
during the game
itself, and the score.
And as a result of that, you
focus on the score a lot more
than you would in
the real world.
In the real world, people would
write everyone's names.
They would write down
the scores.
And at the end of every couple
of hands, people will go and
say, OK, what is your score?
What is your score?
And that's kind of in the
background of your mind, in
the back of your mind.
But it's not something that
is facing you on the
screen all the time.
And as a result of that, what
we've seen is competitive
players who play online get into
this metagame where the
scoring information of all the
partners is so present in
their mind that whole time that
it alters the way they
play the game, and the
strategies they use.
Another unique challenge for the
digital versions is that
people will have a hard
time believing
that AI doesn't cheat.
OK?
A really hard time.
So we have a game.
It's a World War II game.
It's called "Memoir 44."
And it's a game where you
get to roll lots of die.
And when you roll those dices,
people are not willing to
believe that the computer rolls
the same dice you are.
So people ask us, they'll
say, I'm a programmer.
I want to see your routine.
So we show the actual code.
And then they say, I want
to see recalls.
So we published 500,000
game recalls.
And we explained to those
people, oh, by the way, the
dice-rolling function has
no idea who it give that
information to.
So the dice-rolling function is
exactly the same as rolling
the computer dice,
and your dice.
It doesn't know when it's
giving the results.
People still don't believe it.
The reason why people don't
believe it is very simple.
It's a game that you
play on the board.
And we have the position of
different pieces, and so on.
That's going to be of impact
on the strategy.
And that's something that is
kind of expensive to compute,
and in some instances, actually
tough to compute on
the computer.
The flip side of that is with
the computer, what you can
really do much better than 99.9%
of the human population
is you can compute the odds.
And you can compute the
odds very well.
So I'm holding a dice, and I'm
looking for this sample, and
that sample, but not that one.
This is five, and I'm looking
for that one and that one.
The computer will do much better
than the typical human.
So as with all of that, when you
program AI, we say, well,
let's use the computer
strength, and let's
program it that way.
So our AI got really good at
maximizing its dice rolls.
And that, combined with the fact
that the perception of
time changes, and that when
you're playing in the
computer, you see the dice rolls
happen in a shorter, a
compressed period of time.
Totally changes your
perception.
OK?
And it's really rigged up.
I mean, you can show people
the actual evidence.
It's basically we've come to the
conclusion it's impossible
to convince people the
AI isn't cheating.
OK?
The other interesting challenge
with AIs is that
sometimes the AI, the game
looks simple to play.
The rules are simple, like
"Ticket to Ride." So you
think, well, the AI should
be easy to program.
Well, not so.
It can be very difficult.
It can be like really
difficult.
And the flip side of that is
there's games that look
complex to play for humans, and
the AI is actually quite
simple to program.
One thing that we like to do
is we don't think it's that
interesting to try
to develop--
it's challenging, and it's not
that interesting, usually, to
try to develop an AI that
plays like a human does.
Because in that case, just
go and find a friend.
I mean, come on.
It's not that difficult,
especially if
you can play online.
So we tried to take
advantage of that.
So with a game like "Small
World," for instance, we use
the fact that the initial
version of the game was only a
two-player game.
And in the two-player game,
it's a zero-sum game.
So whatever points I'm scoring,
I'm taking away from
you, and vice versa.
And as a result of that, we
used that in the way we
designed the AI.
And people felt that the game
was super aggressive.
It was super aggressive because
you'd put at a stack
of armies like that
on one territory.
And in the regular play in the
real world, people will never
go after that stack.
They're literally physically
intimidated by the height of
your stack.
Even though all you need is
one more token, OK, and it
doesn't matter whether the stack
is that high, or that
high from a score standpoint.
And so we were able to develop
something that played really
fundamentally different.
And that's kind of fun, because
what that shows you is
that when you're developing
digital games the right way,
they will allow you to learn
the game, but they will
scratch a different itch.
So what you get as a player
from playing the digital
version of the game
will be different.
And the pleasure you'll get out
of it, and the frustration
you'll get out of it sometimes,
too, will be
different from the one when
you playing the cardboard.
And that really has made the
game a success, the business a
success, because then you really
do get that feedback
loop where people who play the
physical board games are aware
of the game, and are interested
in playing it online.
And that creates a base level,
if you want, of sales online.
That allows you to be visible
and stay visible if you have a
large number of physical
players out there.
And in turn, because you're
visible in the charts, people
can buy the online version.
Some people will discover the
game online, and eventually
they'll want to go and buy
the physical board game.
Because the physical board
game will give
them different things.
And one of the things that
will be different is the
memories that you
get out of it.
If you think about when you
were playing board games,
maybe as a child, I'm sure
most of you can jog some
memories of some specific
games where you remember
So-And-So did that after
he was going to
capture that territory.
And it's much harder--
I'm not saying it's
impossible--
but it's much harder to have the
same emotional connection
with a digital site.
So being able to play on both
fronts is really something
that we strive to do.
And that's really, I think, that
really captures what we
try to do as a business.
We really enjoy being one foot
on the physical side, one foot
on the digital side.
That allows us to keep the
business interesting because,
frankly, the cardboard side,
it's interesting initially
because the spectrum of time is
so different and it impacts
the way you drive and you
develop your business.
But after a while, you've
figured it out.
OK?
So you understand how that
fragmented, antiquated
distribution network works.
And it kind of gets boring.
The nice thing on the digital
side is things change so
quickly that you always have
to stay on your toes.
And so being able to combine
the two really makes for a
fun, lifestyle business.
And I think that kind of sums
up what I wanted to discuss
about for getting the
design of the games.
And I'd be happy to open
it to Q&A now.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: So why don't you
guys raise your hand, and I'll
run by and put the mike
in front of you.
Obviously, so we can
get it recorded.
AUDIENCE: The digital versions
of your games are so good.
I was just wondering how you
guys made that pivot, or how
you built up the team to
start creating those.
ERIC HAUTEMONT: So I think
there's a couple of things
that gave us an edge.
One is that-- and that goes back
to the fact that people
in the cardboard business
will fail in a hurry.
That's one of the things that,
for us, makes it interesting,
which is that there is
no shortcut, and
you need to go slow.
And we tried to adopt the same
thing with the digital side.
So one of the nice things about
the board game side is
once you have--
It's both the best and the worst
business in the world,
because it's like the book
publishing business.
Until you have a hit, it's
a really, really bad
business to be in.
And I would recommend to no one
interested in making money
to go in the board
game business.
OK?
Because it's expensive
to manufacture.
It's expensive to distribute.
And it's low margins.
OK?
But that's only true until
you get a hit.
And the day you get the next
"Ticket to Ride," or the next
"Harry Potter" in the book
business, that becomes a
wonderful business.
Because once a year, you
call your printer.
You say, please, pretty
please, print
me some more money.
There's very little
competition,
and it lasts forever.
And it's true.
I mean, we look at "Ticket to
Ride." So we came up with
"Ticket to Ride" 10 years ago,
and we've been selling more
"Ticket to Ride" every single
year of the board game.
Every single year than
the year before.
And our marketing expenses
are literally this much.
As my partner and friend, Mark,
likes to say, all the
marketing is in the game box.
We put all the money in the box,
and the word of mouth is
what's going to do it.
Now, the flip side of that
is the word of mouth
only goes so fast.
So if you're in a hurry, just
spend money and waste it.
So I think the luxury of having
those hits under our
belt on the cardboard side has
allowed us to go very slow on
the digital side.
OK?
So the first version of "Ticket
to Ride," the digital
board game, was actually on
the web back in 2005 as a
small Java app.
And initially, it was free.
And what we realized, as people
started playing it, is
that some people were
playing it a lot.
I mean a whole lot.
Like there's some people--
I won't name names-- but there's
some people that have
played in excess of
80,000 games of
"Ticket to Ride" online.
Now, online plays faster than
the real board game, so if
you're really fast and good--
and by the time you're at your
80,000th game, you should be
fast, at least, if not good--
you'd be able to play maybe
three to five minutes, if it's
a two-player game.
But then they do do the math.
80,000 times three to five
minutes, that's a pretty good
chunk of time.
So we realized that maybe
there was a business for
actually selling the
digital versions.
And what really, I think,
allowed us to get to the next
level was the unveiling
of the iPad.
And we have the iPad,
and all the tablets.
It's not specific to the iPad.
But where I think the tablets,
and not the phones, but the
tablets differ from every other
form of device is that
they have this first device that
I think are really-- or
can in certain usage be very
transparent, meaning that you
can play on that device, and you
don't realize consciously
on that, that you're
sitting in front of
an electronic device.
When I'm sitting in front of
computer playing a game of
"Ticket to Ride," I know I'm
intimately aware that I'm in
front of my computer playing
"Ticket to Ride." When you are
playing on the tablet, sometimes
you can forget that.
And it's especially true when
you're playing face to face on
the tablet.
So the answer--
I guess the long-winded winded
answer to your question is the
reason we've been successful, I
think, is we take our time.
We don't hesitate to be late.
So we have lots of people that
come to us, and they say, we
have a new platform.
You must do that.
So a couple of years ago, we had
people say, oh, if you're
not on Social Live, if
you're not on social
networks, you're dead.
And we're like, maybe
we're dead.
Maybe we're not.
The nice thing is we
can afford to wait.
And the same thing was true with
consoles, where people
come in and say, you need
to be on this console.
Well, no, we don't really,
actually, because we're doing
just fine on the
cardboard side.
We've got the digital side
of the business.
And so if we're not on that
version, we can be on the next
version, or the next version.
And by the way, if we miss the
train, maybe that train will
go off road somewhere.
And we don't have to
worry about it.
And we still have some time.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I play "Memorial 44," and
after your comments about the
AI, I was wondering if you've
ever felt the urge to actually
tweak the AI so that
it cheats, but in
favor of the player.
A lot of video games do that.
Like they make it seem like it's
fair, but it's actually
in favor of the player, so the
player doesn't complain.
ERIC HAUTEMONT: No, we don't
for a couple of reasons.
One is an economical reason,
which is that we're a very
small company, actually,
in terms of people.
We are 16 people worldwide, and
that includes the people
that do the physical cardboard
stuff, and all the people who
do the programming and the art
for the online versions.
So once we have a version that
we're happy with, we try not
to tinker with it too much
because it's expensive.
It's expensive not in
terms of money.
It's expensive in terms
of our time.
And whatever time we spend
developing these additional
tweaks to the AI is time that we
don't spend taking the next
game online.
So that's one reason.
The other one is that we
actually think that part of
the fun of doing AIs, or of
playing the AIs, is figuring
out the AI.
It's almost like a puzzle.
And once you've solved that
puzzle, than frankly, we want
to encourage people to
go and play online.
There's no way-- we could have
the entire company work on AIs
for "Memorial 44" for the next
10 years, and I still don't
think we could duplicate the
variety of opponents that are
playing face to face.
AUDIENCE: A short followup.
When can we expect Android
versions of your games?
[LAUGHTER]
ERIC HAUTEMONT: So I'll
give an answer.
I'll give an answer, but before
I give that answer, I
need to promise everyone that
you'll be able to keep your
mouth shut for the next, uh,
for the next two weeks.
[LAUGHTER]
ERIC HAUTEMONT: So is
that a "yes?" OK.
So we'll be shipping--
and I know I've been kind of
famous in the board game
industry, because people--
every time we ship a new version
on the iPhone, or
something, people say, Android,
Android, Android.
And I've actually gone to the
press a couple of years ago on
record, and saying, we don't
want to do Android versions,
and here's why.
And I got a lot of flak for
that from board gamers.
But we actually came in with--
we actually came with a "Ticket
to Ride" version on
the Android tablets.
And I say tablets.
So we work on some
of the large--
I mean, one thing that is
interesting, and kind of
change for a small team like
us on Android, is that you
have this wide variety.
You have this continuum of
phone factors, from like
really tiny phones all the
way to large tablets.
But you'll be able to play
"Ticket to Ride" on tablets.
The game will ship on Google
Play on May 30.
And if some of you are
interested, you can send me an
email after we are done.
You can send me an email at
eric-- that's E-R-I-C--
@daysofwonder.
And if you really can't wait
until May 30, we can probably
get you to download the
application we used to
distribute beta version,
which is [INAUDIBLE]
app, and send you an APK of
the game ahead of time.
The only thing we ask is, as a
company, we tend to be quite
secretive about what we do
until the day we launch.
So you're welcome to email me.
I'll give you a version.
Please don't try to go and pass
it around or anything
like that until May 30.
AUDIENCE: So my daughter and I
would like to play "Ticket to
Ride," but I find when we play
together-- she's eight--
we don't play the sort of
cutthroat game of like, oh,
I'm going to cut you off.
And you can't finish a route.
But we kind of played in a
cooperative way, where oh, I
see you're trying to
build over here.
I'll build over there.
Have you thought about what some
of your games, thinking
about ways you could make them
like cooperative variants of
the games, or cooperative
gameplay, so that for
families and stuff?
Those kind of environments?
ERIC HAUTEMONT: Yeah.
So we actually have a game
called "Shadows Over Camelot,"
which is a game that is actually
built around the
whole idea of being cooperative,
meaning that all
the players together
play against the
game mechanics itself.
Now, even there, I'm
afraid though, we
couldn't quite help it.
So we did put a small wrinkle
in that, which is that even
though all the players are
playing together against the
game mechanic itself, there is
always the possibility, or the
risk, even in your case, that
one of the players is a
traitor, and will win if
everybody else loses.
OK?
But you don't have a guarantee
that that player is there.
And if you want to play it in
purely cooperative mode, you
can do that.
On a game like "Ticket to Ride,"
there's a way to play
cooperatively, like on the
Asia map, for instance.
We have a team version.
So where players have a limited
amount of information,
the connections, how they
can share together.
So you're playing cooperatively,
but you still
playing competitively against
other players.
And the reason for that is,
again, with real board games,
you must use a very simple
set up rules.
Otherwise, you lose the vast
majority of players.
And so it's difficult to keep
the tension that makes a game
fun and tight when being
purely cooperatively.
so unless you design the game
from the ground up for that, I
think it's very difficult to
take a game that is not a
cooperative game and
turn it into one.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering if
you could speak a bit about
the collaboration process
between the company and
working designers, and sort
of like where the work--
how the work is split up.
And also, I'm also curious about
sort of like the origins
of "Ticket to Ride," and
how you got started
creating the game.
ERIC HAUTEMONT: Sure.
OK.
So we're getting at how we
work with game designers.
It really runs the whole gamut
for a number of reasons, one
of which is that we haven't met
two game designers that
are the same.
There's actually very few people
in the business who
make a living, full time,
from game design.
Most of those that do make
a living full time tend
to be in the US.
But there's game designers
all around the world.
And we've seen people that have
submitted prototypes to
us that we're working for the
Secret Service, that we're
working for that Coast Guard, on
the equivalent of the Coast
Guards in other countries.
People that are teachers.
People that are priests.
All kind of people.
And so depending on the work
they do, and the type of
designed they do, the amount
of interactions we have is
more or less significant.
So we have some people that have
worked with us, and they
say, I have a design,
and the design was
perfect from the get-go.
And so the interaction we had
with them was sending a
publishing agreement, and then
keeping them informed as we
went to develop the game from
the graphic design standpoint
that you want.
One thing that we
don't do is--
and that goes back to
the [INAUDIBLE]
collaboration--
is I actually don't believe in
the design by committee.
So when we do graphic design and
things like that, we have
an art director.
We discuss together.
We discussed in the company, but
there's someone that makes
the decision.
And that someone is me, because
I'm the one who is
paying for this mistake if we
screw up, and we don't sell
the board game as well as
I thought we would.
So we inform the game designers,
and we show them
who we're going to work
with, and so on.
But it's not really
collaborative in that we don't
let them decide which
[INAUDIBLE] they are
going to work with.
All the things like that.
OK?
Now, from a gameplay standpoint,
depending on the
game, it can be very
interactive.
So if we take a game like
"Memoir 44," Richard Borg
developed that game,
and designed a
great game about the--
Sorry.
My mind goes blank.
He had designed a great game
about the Civil War.
And we went to him, and we said,
we'd like to do a game
on World War II.
And we spent the better part of
six months working with him
on the game design itself,
tweaking the game design that
he had to make it work
for World War II.
OK?
So it runs the whole gamut.
Now, regarding "Ticket to Ride,"
the way we stumbled on
"Ticket to Ride" is we went to
a small board game conference
in Baltimore that is
held every year.
And now it's moved
to Lancaster,
Pennsylvania, I think.
It's called the World Board
Game Championship.
It's kind of a misnomer to call
it the World Board Game
Championship.
We tend to think of it as
the Baltimore Board Game
Championship, because 95% of the
people there are in close
proximity of the convention.
But it's a great conventional
where people go and play games
competitively for a week
of time every summer.
And we met with Alan there.
We'd never met with
him before.
It was Mark and myself.
And we said, let
me [INAUDIBLE].
And he said, oh, I have these
game that I need to show you.
And he pulled this small
cardboard box, and it says
"Station to Station." And he put
the map on the table that
looked like a cool version
of the original
"Ticket to Ride" map.
And we started playing
the game.
He said, OK, so it's
a very simple game.
Here are the rules.
And so we started playing two or
three times with Mark, and
we look at each other,
and we're like,
yes, this feels good.
And so then [INAUDIBLE]
Alan just wipes off of the whole
map clean and said, OK,
so you understand
how it plays.
So you can take it
home and decide.
And with Mark, we just said,
like, you just stopped the
whole game.
You just destroyed
our whole game.
We were playing!
What did you do?
And to this day, to this day,
I'm not quite sure whether
Alan used that as a genius
marketing trick to really make
sure he had hooked us as
a publisher, or not.
Now, Alan will claim, if you ask
him in public, Alan will
claim no recollection whatsoever
of ever wiping that
board clean.
But that's kind of the
background story behind
"Ticket to Ride."
And what was fun with that, and
that's true of all board
games, is that I then traveled
with that little prototype.
I actually flew to Korea because
back in 2004, there
was kind of this board
game craze in
coffee shops in Korea.
And I wanted to witness
that first hand.
And so I traveled with
that small prototype.
And what I saw there--
and I've seen it again and again
with board games-- is
what's interesting is board
games, if they're really good,
they will work anywhere
in the world.
So no matter whether you speak
the language of the people you
play with or not, you can
have a great time.
And we saw that.
Landed in Korea.
Quickly was in a cafe where I
have no clue what people were
talking about.
OK?
I couldn't understand a word,
and they probably couldn't
understand a word.
You guys probably don't
understand half of the words
I've been talking about.
And I called Mark, and I said,
you know, this game
is going to be big.
We knew right then.
So that's one of the nice things
about the prototypes is
again, even if you have really
bad graphics, you'll know very
quickly, once you play with
people, whether you have a
winner or not.
AUDIENCE: So first of, I wanted
to thank you very much.
I absolutely love "Ticket to
Ride." I actually bought a
copy for my family back home in
Chicago, and they've been
playing it like every day for
the past several months.
ERIC HAUTEMONT: Thank you.
Thank you or sorry?
AUDIENCE: Oh, it's more of
a thank you, actually.
It helped me survive
a few trips home,
which is always nice.
One thing I noticed in
particular, because I play the
tablet version a lot, is that
when you play the tablet
version, it tends to be more of
a single player experience,
even when you're
playing online.
Because your goal is to kind
of finish your routes.
Where when you're playing in
person, there's more of this
competitive edge, where you kind
of want to screw people
over, and you want
to cut them off.
And you want to kind of see
where they're trying to get
to, and cause more mayhem.
Is there any way of kind of
adding that into the digital
version of the game?
I just found that even though
I play both copies, that my
strategy changes from
game to play.
ERIC HAUTEMONT: What you
say is very true.
I think it's very tough on a
game like "Ticket to Ride."
And the reason for that, and
that's something that's shared
with a lot of board game
designs, is that there's
hidden information.
And so because you have it, that
hidden information, it's
very difficult for us to have
a commercially practical
version where you could play
"Ticket to Ride" sharing the
same tablet as your digital
board with other people
sitting across from you.
OK?
And until we get that, so that
means we have to assume, then,
that everybody has a phone,
too, that they can use, to
hold in their hand.
And then you have to
deal with all these
interface issues of, OK--
Again, the real world
is complex, or it's
simpler than it looks.
So when you have real cards in
your hand, you just drop you
cards, and you're done.
If you have a digital device
in your hand, and you're
trying to drop those cards onto
the digital device in the
middle, it gets quickly
pretty awkward.
And you have to worry about your
Bluetooth connection or
your Wi-Fi connection dropping
off, and all kinds of crap
that you don't have to
worry about with a
real deck of cards.
OK?
So for games with hidden
information like "Ticket to
Ride," I'd say it's very
difficult until the technology
gets a lot more transparent.
Now, with games like "Small
World," you can actually play
a game of "Small World" face
to face around the tablet.
And in that case, we actually
see the behavior on the type
of play very much being the
same, with the kind of
aggressiveness you describe,
and so on.
What's interesting is we run a
"Ticket to Ride" tournament,
championship tournament.
Real "Ticket to Ride" with
the real board game.
And because we have people that
have played 80,000 games,
where lots of people online that
think like, they're the
king of "Ticket to Ride," and
nobody can beat them.
So when we started doing
national qualifications for
that tournament, we had lots
of people who said, I'm so
good online.
I'm not even going to go
for the qualifiers.
I'm just going to go in the
actual competition, and I'm
going to crush everyone.
And I'd say over 90% of people
that had that kind of
attitude, got their clock
cleaned when they actually
played the real, physical
board game.
OK?
Because it plays different.
It really does.
And we had the final where
we had one person--
it was interesting.
We had the final where we had
one best one that actually
played a lot of physical board
game versions of "Ticket to
Ride."
And we had this opponent, who
was the opposite of my
finalist, who was actually a
professional player, in that
he didn't really particularly
care, at the time, about
"Ticket to Ride." He cares about
playing tournaments with
money to win.
And he studies the game, and
he just goes after that.
And so he had only played like
five games of "Ticket to Ride"
in real life, and a couple
of games online.
But he'd studied all about the
ticket distribution, and
everything else.
And he finished second.
So I guess experience
does pay off.
But it shows there's
different sides.
To us, that's part of what's
fun, is what you get out of
playing online tends to be
different from what you get
out of playing the physical
board game.
And so eventually, you
end up buying both,
which we love you for.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
We just have time for a
couple more questions.
There's one from VC, and
then we're going to
take one over here.
So one from VC from Henry.
He asks, "Given your emphasis
on simplicity of design, how
do you feel about the recent
popularity of really complex
games, like 'Fantas.y Flight,"
coming out of "Fantasy
Flight," like "Civilization,"
"Ora et Labora?"
ERIC HAUTEMONT: So I think it's
interesting that the more
complex games can be
very exciting.
And it's interesting you
mentioned "Civilization,"
because the old Avalon Hill
"Advanced Civilization" is
kind of the all-time favorite
of mine, even though I would
never publish it as
a board game.
I have memories of playing down
the block, literally, for
like 14 hours in a row.
And that's some of
my best memories.
I think the difference between
the long games, or the simple
games and the complex
games, is the--
it goes back to the
word of mouth.
The word-of-mouth factor on
the complex games is a lot
harder to grow fast.
And so you have a much
smaller population.
So you have people that
have become, I'd
say, board game literate.
And so you have people that
actually-- you have a small
segment of the population
that actually enjoys
learning new games.
And so when we go to like Alan
Moon's Gathering of Friends,
there are people who are there
just to play new games.
And if you propose to them to
play a game they've already
played, they're going
to say, no.
I actually want to
play a new game.
And so there's people that
kind of enjoy that mental
gymnastic, if you want.
And once you get over the hump,
I can see why people
enjoy that.
But that's a very
small minority.
AUDIENCE: So this is a slightly
different question.
But you're talking about
ensuring the dice rolling in
"Memoir 44," and games
like that, was fair.
So I was curious as to why the
die in "Small World" has the
one across from the three,
instead of having the three
sides all across from blank
faces, which would have a
greater guarantee of
having a fair die.
ERIC HAUTEMONT: Actually,
it's a good question.
Because in the game itself, that
difference, when you look
at the impact of the difference,
makes no
difference.
So we went with whatever was
the simplest for the game,
which was easiest for the shop
design, to give to the tool
manufacturer to do.
So that's the actual
reason why.
We had a simulation when we
did that World Board Game
Championship with "Ticket
to Ride." One of the two
finalists came to me and said,
OK, so I looked at whether the
tournament rules work.
And how are we going to
decide who starts?
It was the first person
to win two games.
And since there's no tie, within
three games, you know
what happens.
And he's like, how are we going
to decide who's going to
start the first game?
And I looked at the guy,
and I said, say what?
And he said, yeah, there's
an advantage to
whoever starts first.
And I said, well, yeah, there's
a theoretical advantage.
And the guy got like really--
So we said, OK, fine.
So I went to see the
other finalist.
I said, OK.
So that guy wants to discuss
who's going to start.
And the other finalist looked at
me, and he said, that's OK.
let him start.
I'll just work a little
bit harder.
And then he proceeded
to just crush him.
And he won two games in a row.
So I guess that kind of
sums up my view about
those kind of things.
They're kind of fun to think
up from a math standpoint.
From a practical standpoint--
I'll give you the dice
design that favors
your odds any time.
AUDIENCE: About the online
versus offline gaming.
So in offline, one
of the biggest--
the thing that I enjoy most
is pitting people
against each other.
And you're like, oh,
he's leading.
You should attack him,
and so forth.
And that like doesn't translate
to online at all.
And so I've been thinking.
I saw this implemented for
"Dominion." I think it's over
in Google Hangouts.
And letting people like see
each other, and then like
encouraging that interaction.
What do you think about that?
Could that be?
ERIC HAUTEMONT: The only thing
about that, the only
reservation I have about those
kind of things-- and we
[INAUDIBLE]
people.
That's why we don't implement
them ourselves.
We let people, if they want--
and we know there's some
people, sometimes, that actually
will literally open a
chat channel, and just like
trash talk with each other
during a game.
The reason we don't support that
directly in the game--
besides the fact that it's work
that we'd rather spend on
designing other games--
so what I want to say is we're
always leery of things that
remove transparency.
We think it's already such a
challenge to translate a
physical board game
properly online.
That the more tools, the more
technology you add, it's very
difficult to do that in a way
that is really transparent.
So even though when I'm playing
in real life, it's
very easy for me to do some
trash talk, if I have to go
and actually type that,
we think that's a big
distraction.
And that's not a very
transparent way of
communicating with people.
And so that's the other reason
why we don't care so much
about those kinds of things.
We're really striving for, I
think, the technology not
getting in the way.
I mean, that's one thing that is
fascinating to us, being in
Silicon Valley, there's
all these people--
Every three months, there's
someone who's come out with a
new dice design.
And they go, Look.
There's this superduper
electronic dice, and it's got
a USB connection.
It's got a hard drive in it, and
it does all these things.
I'm like, dice have worked fine
for thousands of years.
OK?
What's the point?
And so we try and--
On the one hand, we look at
new technology, and we're
really curious to see what
happens with Google Glasses in
terms of certain types of hidden
information that we
think it could take care
of during the games.
At the same time, we're really
careful to go slow, and not do
things that are non-transparent,
and really
become more cumbersome, and
remove more than they add.
MALE SPEAKER: Let's give Eric
a big round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
ERIC HAUTEMONT: Thank you.
Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks
again for coming.